hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political journalist for the
financial times jasmine cameron chileshi
and the male's deputy political editor
john stevens so a very good evening to
both of you and you are both going to be
with us until around midnight so good to
see you let's um get to the front pages
though first of all and the financial
times leads with the uk and the eu
leveling sanctions against the russian
military and hundreds more of its
oligarchs
the metro focuses on the implications
those sanctions will have on access to
luxury items
ukraine will never join nato reach the
front of the daily telegraph
and the guardian also looks at this
story as president zielenski
acknowledges that ukraine will not
become a member of nato
and the times also leads with that story
the front of the mirror looks at boris
johnson's trip to saudi arabia to talk
oil and energy supplies
and in other news the front of the sun
profiles the people bidding to take over
chelsea fc after the departure of roman
abramovich
and just a reminder by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out those
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
so we're joined tonight by jasmine
cameron cheleshi and john stevens so
jasmine first of all a few of the front
pages are focusing on what vladimir
zelinski the ukrainian president said
today about nato membership you picked
out the telegraph first of all
so remind us what he said and what the
implications of his statement could
potentially be
his comments were quite striking he was
essentially saying that he recognized
the fact that ukraine isn't going to be
a part of nato anytime soon and if we
remember before the invasion this was
one of president putin's key demands of
um western leaders i think it's
important to see his comments in the
context of the fact that he's been
repeatedly urging um nato's tata for
action he's been calling for no-fly
zones but the west western countries
have sort of said you know these are
limits of our help we can give you
certain weapons but we can't take
further steps and so he's acknowledging
the west position and how far they're
willing to go and he's also trying to
strike up and trying to continue
negotiations with russia and trying to
agree some sort of ceasefire now the
daily telegraph quotes government
insiders that say there's a bit of
skepticism on the uk end as to whether
you know the ceasefire can actually be
actualized and how far negotiations and
go but president zlenski's you know in a
way trying to offer some sort of olive
branch the russian regime and sort of
outline that actually ukraine isn't
going to join nato it's not going to
become for at all or partnering with
western allies it's just looking for for
peace so i think his his comments are
striking in that regard well yes john
what do you make of this it's covered in
the guardian as well ukraine's nato
concession they say as airstrikes batter
capital i mean obviously peace talks are
continuing which is some people say is
obviously a good thing that both sides
are continuing to talk but could this
potentially lay the groundwork for for
some kind of deal or is the truth that
nato membership is just one element of
russia's concerns they're also deeply
worried about the country's pull towards
europe as well
yeah and i think that everyone clearly
is quite hopeful that there might be a
piece still but i think everyone's got
to be realistic here that this is not
going to be the single ask that russia
is going to put on the table you've got
to think about all the other things that
they're going to want as well
they're going to demand parts of ukraine
territory of ukraine i think that would
be more difficult for zelensky to get an
agreement on that they're going to lock
off parts of his country obviously lots
of people
in ukraine wouldn't be happy about that
and you look at the scale of the russian
invasion clearly what vladimir putin was
hoping to get was full
a complete regime change you know he
wants to take out kiev he wants the
whole government to be taken over to
take over the whole country you look at
the number of troops that he's massed on
the borders and so
i think the some agreement that ukraine
doesn't join nato which clearly isn't on
the cards anyway at the moment i just
don't think it's going to be enough and
i think actually
that's why the government is quite
skeptical about whether this is actually
going to lead to some sort of peace deal
and jasmine a quick reflection on the
fact that as john was saying there the
ambition clearly by russia was to take
over the whole country they thought
they'd do it relatively quickly i think
they imagined that they would be able to
move in on kiev within the first few
days
they're still
not in control of that city at three
weeks on and today we did see this visit
didn't we by the czech polish and
slovenian prime ministers
into that city i mean quite symbolic
that they were able to travel there and
show their support
for for vladimir silenski
i think so and i do think president
putin really underestimated um the
strength of the ukrainian people the
ukrainian government um i think in many
ways people also underestimated the
unity of the west i'm sure he was hoping
that western countries would be
preoccupied with recovery from
coronavirus wouldn't really be
you know it wouldn't really present such
a united front but actually as we've
seen when it whether it comes to things
like sanctions or the sort of verbal
messages that are coming out from places
like the us the uk and the eu
they are sort of combining the unified
voice on this and so i think in many
respects president putin you know this
whole invasion hasn't really gone to
plan but i do think it is important to
remember that
russia has vast military strength and is
willing to use it and i think this may
unfortunately be a long protracted
conflict and unfortunately that will
mean you know more front pages showing
um on cities and and you know that will
increase the number of people that are
having to to flee for their lives so i
think you know we might be in this for
the long haul
well yes and and you mentioned a unified
front on sanctions there jasmine and the
financial times picks up on that element
of the story john tomorrow doesn't it uh
west turns up heat on moscow with moves
against oligarchs and the military and
this is not just the uk
expanding their list of of people and
items that are being sanctioned but the
eu as well
yeah the eu of sanctioned very well rich
today who obviously the uk
sanctuary was the end of last week and
the uk today is sanctioned i think it's
370
individuals and entities and at the
start of the sanctions process it did
seem to be going a bit slow people were
quite frustrated by how it seemed to be
taking a bit of time but they seem to
have really got into gear now and one of
the changes that's made things easier
is that law that was passed by
parliament that means that if an ally of
the uk someone like the eu sanctions
someone then the uk can very quickly
just mirror that repeat that and do
exactly the same thing that they don't
have to go through in the same detail
to prove the links between these
individuals and russia so it does seem
like a much quicker process they also
look at the other ideas that they're
starting to look at one of the things
that they've announced today is this ban
or luxury goods things like cars watches
are being able to be
imported into russia and that's really
turning the screw on kind of the
influencer generation
these young people who are the children
of oligarchs who like to flaunt the
wealth that they've got on instagram
it's kind of track down on that and stop
and be able to get hold of these luxury
goods so it's targeting russia in loads
of different areas in those different
ways
and jasmine i've just noticed your
byline on this article i think we should
give you credit you have got a couple of
others there alongside you but a quick
word from you then given that you've
written the article um so what do you
think then the uk as genre is referring
to there has been accused of being a bit
slow on sanctions does it feel now
like it's it's doing enough and
has the delay meant that some of these
people may have been able to shift their
assets
i mean i think
it is fair to say there was a lot of
criticism towards the government at the
very beginning i think their initial
argument was always that it's going to
be slow and steady they're going to
gradually ramp up the sanctions um you
know in a proportionate manner and i
think they have done and i think the
passing of the legislation earlier this
week has really helped the uk align its
sanctions um regime with the eu and the
us
i think as john was saying i think the
the sanctions have been somewhat
effective in trying to drive a wedge
between putin and the people and so some
of these sanctions it's impacting the
russian economy it's impacting
day-to-day lives or russian individuals
whether it's you know whether or not
they can go to ikea or the products that
are important exports out of the country
and so i think you know we are seeing an
impact but i think the big question for
me is that you know
the sanction hasn't haven't really acted
as a deterrent so we're seeing the west
escalate sanctions but it hasn't
necessarily slowed putin down even if
the impact on the russian economy
russian economy has been immense and so
there is that question of what the end
goal of the sanctions really is and at
what point does it stop at what point
you know does it get to the fact that
there is you know we've imposed so many
sanctions and it's now starting to
influence what's happening in the west
and sort of western economies we know
there's already concerns about the cost
of living crisis and so the sort of the
end game of these sanctions is a bit
unclear to me well yes and let's just
have a quick look at how the metro
covers it they focus on on the bling
aspect the luxury goods aspect you're
not blinging anymore is there a headline
there but you talk about the cost of
living crisis jasmine if we look john at
the front of the mirror
they focus on the concern about the uk
weaning itself off russian oil and gas
and this proposed trip by the prime
minister to to saudi arabia to try to
persuade them to perhaps increase
production to try and help with the
price
of oil and but coming under criticism
from the mirror there
yeah we all know that the difficulties
that people are facing with the cost of
living at the moment anyone who goes to
fill up their car the moment can see how
much the prices have gone up and so you
can see why boris johnson's trying to
find a way around this trying to find
other countries that we can possibly get
oil and gas from i think the decision to
move away from taking stuff from russia
and then going to authoritarian regimes
like saudi arabia
is a very difficult one especially when
you've got the context of just this
weekend you had saudi execute 81 people
i think that's why it is quite a
difficult path for the government to
tread and why there's a lot of
campaigners who are quite unhappy about
the prime minister making this trip
yeah let's move on we're trying to
squeeze a lot in here jasmine so many
different elements of this story aren't
there we're going to turn to the front
of the times next because and they've
got a photograph here on their front
page
of people who have left ukraine and this
is focusing on the uk's new scheme to
try to house refugees here
and it's been particularly striking
obviously the the scheme was only
announced a couple days ago but we're
seeing thousands of of british people
sort of certainly register their
interests and say that they'd be willing
to take um those who were fleeing from
ukraine in and i think that's been
really encouraging i think the outward
sort of public generosity doesn't
detract from the fact that
the home office has come under a lot of
criticism in recent days over its
handling of the refugee scheme and you
know there are all sorts of questions
over pretty patel's involvement and what
more the government could have could
have done really and i think it's quite
striking that tory mps both publicly and
privately have also posted a bit of
frustration they're getting letters from
constituents he was sort of saying
seeing what's happening on the tv
screens on the front of the newspapers
we want to help what can we actually do
and so i think the big question for the
government in the next couple of days
will be how is the scheme sort of
implemented practically and is it you
know how are we making sure that those
who are vulnerable are getting the
adequate support they need a house where
they need to go and just sort of helped
to integrate into into uk society and
give them the support to get to get jobs
and go into schools and that sort of
thing okay and yes and i think the
latest figure just after nine o'clock
was 122 000 just over that um had
applied or expressed interest in that
scheme so an extraordinary response
jasmine and john for the moment thanks
very much indeed i'm very pleased to say
though you will be staying on with us
into the 11 o'clock hour but for the
moment thank you
let's take a quick look at the weather
now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well there'll be some rain tomorrow
mainly for england and wales but high
pressure will keep things settled by the
end of the week many places will start
cloudy and dry but there'll be outbreaks
of rain for eastern scotland cumbria and
west wales there'll be apache frost for
ireland northern ireland and northwest
scotland
low cloud and rain will take over more
of england and wales during the morning
but the southwest looks mainly dry
expect some brightness there
eastern scotland will see further patchy
rain too
and elsewhere it'll be largely dry with
plenty of sunshine but there will be a
few showers in the far west some of them
will be heavy it'll be cooler than today
for most of us
eastern scotland wales and western
england will turn increasingly sunny
during the afternoon
elsewhere though there'll be little
change but rain over central and eastern
england will become heavy in places
perhaps leaving saharan dust deposits
the odd rumble of thunder is possible
too
and looking ahead to thursday that's
going to bring showers i'm afraid some
heavy but much of england wales will
look dry and sunny
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up next on sky news at 11 a
35-hour curfew is enforced in kiev
tonight after the city's mayor warned of
difficult hours to come
[Music]
so
[Music]
you